I don't I don't even say bye no more.
I be like Mwah, no boss.
I am very sure
I'm not the only South African girl that's happy
that South African men are attracted to a different
kind of woman.
And you know how the Nigerians left Nigeria
and came to South Africa to find South African women
and date South African women?
I think South African men should do the same thing
and go to Cape Venda
and don't forget your G b v.
Like go with it guys.
You see that gender based violence thing?
Take it with y'all to Cape Venda.
Like we can even open a group chat,
contribute money so that you guys can actually go like,
isn't that amazing?
And you know what's exciting?
Maybe now that you find other women
like beautiful,
exciting and everything,
you guys will actually spend on them.
You'll give them princess treatment
you that you do the most for them.